كيف صحتك احلام نعم
احلام صباح الخير مرحبا صباح النور بالفعل
بالفعل صباح النور مرحبا بكم في هذا
المباشر من تونس نظريه الارض المسطحه تعود
من جديد الى الصوره بعد تصريحات ملات
الدنيا وشغلت الناس للاعلامي التونسي
المعروف اشرف الكعلي اثناء ظهور اعلامي له
موفى الاسبوع الفار اكد فيه بانه بعد
مطالعاته لعديد الكتب واطلاعه على مجموعه
من الكتب الدينيه والكتب الاخرى تاكد من
ان الارض هي مسطحه وليست مدوره وبان هذه
النظريه هي غير صحيحه وهناك ربما مغالطات
للناس في هذا الشان جمعيه العلوم الفلك
دخلت وتناشدت وسائل الاعلام بان يتوخوا
الحذر ويستدعوا اولي الاختصاص وان يحذروا
من هذه ربما الادعاءات التي نعتتها
بالادعاءات المتخل فه بين ظفرين وطالبت من
الاعلام ان يكون اكثر حذر في هكذا مسائل
نعم يعني عدنا الى عصر جاليليو احلام مره
اخرى
بالفعل طيب خليني هذه الاشكاليه لم تطرح
اول مره من تونس نعم طب خلينا شويه نرجع
لرمضان ونتكلم عن البريك الطبقه الرمضاني
في تونس الاشهر في تونس هل ممكن ان
تتحدثين اكثر ماذا يحدث اليوم بتعرفي يمكن
اسمه بريك طبق
صحيح صحيح صحيح انه البريكه المقبلات
الاشهر كان في الحقيقه
كان في الحقيقه نجم السوشيال ميديا في
الايام الفارطه خاصه بعد تصريحات الدكتوره
القلب والشرايين الدكتوره ايمان الفرادي
التي طالبت مرضى القلب والشرايين وكذلك
الناس الذين يعانون ربما من زياده في
الوزن بتوخي الحذر بعدم اكل البريك بصفه
يوميه لانه يحتوي على البيض الذي من شانه
ان يلحق الاضرار بالصحه باعتباره من
المواد الدسمه للاسف رواد السوشيال ميديا
لم يطلعوا على التصريح كاملا وبمجرد
سماعهم لمساله البريك الا وشنو هجمه كبيره
وانتشرت التعليقات التي تحذر الدكتوره
ايمان الفرادي بالطبيعه بكل فكاهه يقولون
نهايه كل شيء الا البريك يا دكتوره لان
البريك هو من الاطباق التي لا تغيب عن
موائد التونسي في رمضان شو القصه اليوم
كله اكل باكل شهي ويعني من السبع عشر
رمضان خلينا بتونس احلام بنحكي عن الامن
التونسيه يحبت معركه صحيح الامن التونسي
يحبط معركه مولوتوف بين مجموعه من
التلاميذ والمفاجاه هو مكان التخطيط لها
شو القصه
بالفعل مكان التخطيط هو المفاجاه لان
التخطيط لهذه الحادثه المؤسفه بالطبع
لانها تدور بين تلاميذ او لانها كانت من
المفترض لا قدر الله ان تدور بين تلاميذ
صغار كان شبكات التواصل الاجتماعي هؤلاء
التلاميذ خططوا لهذه المعركه وجهزوا عبوات
الموروثوف التي
فيما بعد تم الامن قام الامن بحجزها وهي
عباره عن 16 عبوه مولوتوف وقاموا بتخبئتها
في مستودع مهجور وقاموا بالاعداد لكل هذا
عن طريق شبكات التواصل الاجتماعي والامن
تفطن الى هذا المخطط عبر شبكات التواصل
الاجتماعي وقام بالتحرك فورا وحجز العبوات
المولوتوف وكذلك استشار النيابه العموميه
التي اذنت للاسف بايقاف جميع التلاميذ
الذين تورطوا في الاعداد لهكذا حادثه التي
سوف كانت سوف تكون خطيره جدا لانها كانت
سوف تتم بين من التلاميذ
احلام بس اريد اشكرك اول شيء وبعدين يعني
انت حضرتي البريك عشان بكره ولا بعد ما
حضرتي
[موسيقى]
لا لا مازال لانه البريكه تحيه وتم تحضيره
بشكل يومي يعني العجين يتم تحريره بشكل
يومي وكذلك الطبق يتم اعداده بشكل يومي
لانه يتم تناوله ساخنا مباشره بعد اذان
المغرب اي تقريبا بعد الدقائق الاولى يلا
صحه وعافيه احلام العبدلي مراسله صباح
العربيه في تونس شكرا لك